Speaker 1: All right.
Let's continue next with.
How about Josh from Florida?
Just from Fort, Florida.
Welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 4: Hello?
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Perfect.
Yeah.
With the Santas going, you know, full crazy,
I would say.
What?
What can we do?
You know, in upcoming elections to sort of
curb his, you know, power grab.
Speaker 1: Are you saying power grab within
Florida or the idea of a power grab by running
and winning the Republican primary?
Speaker 4: Kind of both, But I. I'm thinking
less and less he's actually going to run for
president.
Speaker 1: And if he does, I'm thinking less
and less that he has a shot to win.
I mean, I tend to agree with you on that.
I mean, here's the thing in Florida.
Florida has become an idea in a sense.
I don't know how else to say it.
And it's of quite a right wing idea.
The thing, even though Florida has millions
and millions of Democrats and left leaning
leaning people and there are beautiful left
leaning parts of Florida.
Florida has become sort of the idea of we're
going to do whatever the hell we want and
we're going to be anti-woke and we're going
to be for freedom.
The way they describe it, freedom to spread
COVID at UFC events, I guess, in the middle
of a pandemic, whatever.
So the problem in Florida, to me is less about
the political makeup, although it's quite
plausible that there are more Republicans
than Democrats.
But it's about the strength that the right
wing ideology has gained in Florida, where
a lot of left leaning people are just disaffected
and they're either thinking about leaving
or they just feel like they politically don't
have a home or don't get involved in politics
or whatever the case may be.
So as a place where many people move to Florida,
obviously one approach would be have more
Democrats moved to Florida and then changed
the balance.
But it's not really clear that that that's
a strategy.
I think it really has to be about Democrats
rebuilding in Florida from the ground up in
a more modern way.
It's less about like Debbie Wasserman Schultz's
and more about some new type of Democrat.
I think there's going to have to be sort of
like a rebranding of Florida Democrats in
order to seize power back from the way DeSantis
has grabbed it.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
The problem I feel is that so many people
look at people who aren't, you know, progressives
or Democrats.
They look at a lot of stuff and they go, Oh,
that's too radical for me.
And and I'm like, What's so radical?
What's so radical about?
Moving forward and progressing as a society.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, here's the thing.
This goes to what the caller earlier said.
Part of conservatism is conserving some prior
state of things.
Now, if you ask them, where is the pin that
you would drop in the timeline for what you
want to conserve?
Some might say the eighties, some might say
the fifties, some might say right before women
could vote.
Some could say there were then were still
slaves.
But fundamentally, it's the idea that we should
do things the way we used to do them, simply
because it's the way we used to do them.
And for a progressive, that's a fundamentally
flawed idea.
Speaker 4: Right.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen.
Think about all of the areas in which we say
it'd be crazy to do things the way we're used
to them in medicine.
We're going to do things the way we used to
do them because that's how we used to do them.
In terms of transportation, we're going to
get rid of planes and get rid of cars and
go to horses in you know, in all of these
different things.
We would say, that's crazy.
So why is it supposedly acceptable in certain
other areas?
I think it's a flawed idea at its core.
Speaker 4: You, right?
Well, I'm with you.
All right.
Thank you for everything you do.
Speaker 1: Josh from Florida, thank you so
very much for the call.
I really do appreciate that.
Why don't we go next to.
Oh, I don't know.
How about Adrian from San Francisco?
Adrian from San Francisco.
Welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Thank you, David.
I'm not in the one in South America.
Speaker 1: Okay, you're right.
You're in San Francisco, California.
Speaker 4: That's right.
How are you, David?
Speaker 1: I'm doing.
Speaker 4: Well.
David, one thing I wanted to discuss with
you today was the problem of homelessness
in California as a whole.
I mean, in our state, we've spent over $10
billion in the past four years on homelessness.
And oftentimes there's sort of this perceived
dichotomy of, well, you can't you have to
sacrifice safety for compassion or the other
way around.
So given that we spend so much money, but
programs seem to be extremely ineffective.
What's your take on terms of, number one,
the strategies to actually solve this problem?
And number two, why do you think, despite
having spent so many resources today, we haven't
really done anything to to help solve or fix
this problem?
Well.
Speaker 1: Homelessness is such a complicated
issue.
So it's interesting you asked this on the
Wednesday show.
We covered Donald Trump's video where he says
he will create mandatory tent cities, which
homeless people will be brought to on busses.
And that's the couldn't couldn't have a worse
solution to homelessness.
You're further stigmatizing homeless people.
You're taking them away from where the jobs
are.
Those tent camps invariably become overpopulated
and sanitation becomes an issue like that's
the totally wrong approach.
Now what will work?
There is no one thing that will work, but
a few things that have to be done to deal
effectively with homelessness.
And part of, you know, the you're asking why
hasn't the money spent worked?
If you only do like one or two of these things,
it doesn't work because you're not actually
solving the problem.
So we really have to deal with why people
become homeless to begin with.
So, number one, affordability of housing.
Housing is really expensive in California
and in particular in the parts of California
that have the jobs and the people where most
people would try to be.
So you've got to increase the availability
of affordable housing, how you do it.
Okay.
You've got to figure that out.
To expand access to mental health and substance
abuse treatment have to do it.
We hear about, oh, we're going to do it.
But like, how exactly do you do it?
What are the programs?
Is it properly funded?
And you have to make sure people know about
them.
Number three, you've got to provide job training
and employment support.
Just getting you know, you create a housing
place and you just give homeless people housing.
Great.
But are they actually at a place where they
can get themselves a job and are they properly
trained to have a job and reenter the workplace,
particularly if they've been out of a job
for a decade and have been homeless for a
decade.
So you've got to do the job training and employment
support.
You probably need to do something about folks
kind of exiting the criminal justice system
into homelessness.
There's like kind of very mediocre halfway
houses, but there's lack of stable housing
for people when they exit the criminal justice
system.
So they'll be number four.
And the number five, you probably need more
of a social safety net, which has, you know,
temporary assistance, food stamps, different
things need to expand it probably by getting
services to more people.
Like that's a lot of stuff.
And it's very easy to say like, well, we've
done some of that, but you really need to
do all of it because homelessness is such
a complicated problem.
Speaker 4: You're absolutely right.
I agree on all five of your points, David.
But, you know, one of the things that's frustrating
to me as a resident is that, you know, the
city of San Francisco spends $120,000 a year
per homeless person.
And so, you know, the money is there.
We have the money and the resources, but somehow
it's not actually translating to anything
effective because those people still need
help.
Those people are still suffering on the streets.
And so fundamentally, there's this disconnect
where we see we're paying our taxpayer dollars
to try to help these people.
Speaker 1: So now, hold on a second, Adrian.
I'm not finding that San Francisco spends
120 grand a year per homeless person.
What I am finding is that for the shelter
beds, there are 70 grand a year per shelter
beds spent.
Of course, not all homeless people are even
participating in the shelter system.
That's still a lot of money.
And it seems like there's waste there.
But I'm not I'm not finding that number that
you're you're pointing out.
Speaker 4: David, is there a way I can later
on provide links or resources so we can email.
Speaker 1: Info it David Pakman dot com.
I'll look into that.
And listen, you're 100% correct with the general
sentiment, Adrian.
Whatever the numbers are, that people's tax
money is going into, what you are told are
programs meant to deal with an issue.
The issue isn't being dealt with and I'm right
there with you on that, whatever the numbers
are.
Speaker 4: Great.
Thanks so much, David.
Speaker 1: All right, Adrian from San Francisco.
Important issue.
Let's take a very quick break.
We're going to continue with the phones in
just a moment.
Just hang on if you're waiting to talk to
me.
And we'll be right back.